Transcriber: Hebatullah Ahmed Mofeed
Gözden geçirme: Ilayda Gokgoz
Herkese Merhaba.
Benim adım Emre Yusufi
sanatla ediniyorum.
10 yılı aşkın bir süredir yurtiçinde ve
yurtdışında çeşitli sanat galerilerinde,
fuarlarda da müzelerde sergilenmekteyim
Gücün tanrısı olarak bilinden, her
külüb modern dünyaya adapte ettiğim
bir sanatım var.
Ortaokul ve lise yıllarında böyle defterim
eskiz ve çizimlerle doluydu.
Öyle dersi derste dinleyen
bir çocuk değildim.
Yazılı ve ezbere dayalı şeyler
de aram çok iyi umut için.
İşte okulumu okul sondan
üçüncü olarak bitirdim.
Bu benim cesaretimi çok ayırmanız.
Çünkü ben kendime karşı çok dürüstüm
yani bir avukat işte ne bilim mühendis
yada bir doktor olamayacaktım.
Bugün beni dinleyen ve kendine karşı
dürüst olan herkesin
çok şanslı olduğunu söyleyebilirim.
Tabi insan kendi şansını kendi yaratıyor.
Buna geleceğiz ama kendine karşı
dürüst olmak ne demek?
Ben biraz ondan bahsedeceğim size.
Ben bunu iki ayırıyorum.
Birincisi kendi kimliğimize
karşı olandır üstünüz
ikincisi de fikirlerimiz olandır üstünüz
Meselen ben bir fikir adamıyım
ve hayatımı, işte fikirlerimi
görsele dökerek yaşıyorum.
Özgün bir fikrin gücüne çok inanıyorum.
Bugün özgün bir fikri olmayan biri onu
pazarlamaya kalkarsa
eminim bir yerde patlayacatır.
Yani biri çıkacak tersine bir hanesini
fikrine bakışta bu da
yapılmış var diyecektir.
Bu noktada biraz cesaretten
da bahsetmek lazım.
Çünkü o özgün fikre ulaşmak için
cesaret de bize gerekiyor.
Illaki görmüşsünüzdür ama
bunu kesin yapmışlardır.
Sana gelene kadar.
Peki ya yapmamışlarsa.
Siz bunu yapacak kadar kendinizi
cesur hissediyor musunuz?
Ya da Hayatınızı o inandınız fikri
adıyacak kadar cesur musunuz?
Ben şanslı bir çocuktum.
Beni çok özgür yetiştiren
ebeveynleri sahibtim.
Çocukluk odamın duvarı tuvalet gibiydi.
Her şeyi yazıyordum, çiziyordum
Resimlerle boğudum.
Denemekten asla çekinmiyordum.
Belki de ben o yüzden özgür
bir çocuk olarak yetiştim.
Şimdi insan kendi kimine karşı dürüst
olduğunda hayatta nerede durduğunu da
daha iyi şekillendire biliyor.
Mesela eğer sesiniz iyi değilse bir
şarkıcı olamazsınız
ya da işte
kan görmeye da inanmıyorsanız
işte genel cerrah olamazsınız.
Ve ben de kendime karşı çok dürüstüm
ve ne olamayacağım biliyordum.
Ama daha önemli bir şey var.
Ne olacağım da biliyordum ve hayatımda
hep bu plana sadık kaldım.
Başta dedi ki insan kendi şansını kendi
yaratır diye, işte
bu şansı yaratan için
böyle bir plana ihtiyaç var.
Çünkü o plan sayesinde hayatta
nerede durdunuz,
o şansın nerede beklediğinizi
şekillendiriyor.
Sorarım size, işte sizce o şansın
gelmesini umduğumuz yardım bekliyorsunuz.
Size kendi sanat kariyerini şekillendiren
bir olaydan bahsetmek istiyorum.
Bir koleksiyonerin beni
Londra'ya davet etti.
Tanışmak üzere benim içinde
çok güzel bir fırsat.
Çünkü ben daha şehri daha
önce görmemiştim.
Londra’yı.
Gittim, kendisi ile tanıştım.
Eserim hakkında ve sanat hakkında
biraz konuştuk.
Akabinde daha sonra
randevulaşmak üzere ayrıldık.
İşte turistik açıdan bir fırsattı,
Londra’ya daha önce görmemiştim.
Elimde cep telefonu işte haritalara
bakarak o sokak senin,
Bu sokak benim geziyorum.
Bir ara
New Bond Street adında bir sokağı sattım.
Ve gördüm ki uluslararası anlamda
neredeyse hayran kaldığım bütün sanatçılar
ve onları temsil eden
çok çok iyi galeriler
hepsi aynı sokakta konumlanmış.
Şimdi işiniz sanat üretmek olduğunda
böyle bir ortam
hakikaten tüyleriniz diken diken ediyor.
Ama biraz da sizi ürkütüyor.
Çünkü seviyenin nerede olduğunu gördüğünüz
biraz korkuyorsunuz, açacağız.
Ama hiç unutmam o zaman ben şöyle
bir şey demiştim kendi kendime.
Eğer dünyada böyle bir ortam varsa
ve ben buna dahil değilsem
artık üretme sen de olur.
Çünkü benim gözlerim burayı gördüm.
Ve sanırım şanslıydım.
Farkındaydım.
Doğru zamanda doğru yerdeydim ve
adım atma cesaretine de sahibtim.
Ne o da adımı attım.
Ne yaptım?
Bir galerin içeri girdim.
Şimdi tesadüf bu ya.
Daha önce acaba ya bu adam benden mi
esinlenmiş dediğim
bir sanatçının işi duruyor karşında iş
gerçekten benim içime çok benziyor
uzun uzun  İşe bakar oldum ve ata bindi.
Daha sonradan galerinin müdürü olduğunu
öğrendiğim kişi benim yanıma geldi.
Koleksiyoner siniz herhalde dedi.
Çünkü epey ilgilendiğiniz görünüşte dedi.
Ben de hayır dedim.
Ben koleksiyoner değilim, ben sanatçıyım
ve işin asla bu işin benim işlemez
ne kadar benzediğine bakıyordum.
Dinci tıbbi adam bir şaşırdı dedi.
Sizin işiniz derken dedi.
Ben çok uzun süredir Herkül temalı
heykeller yapıyorum ve o eserlerin de
binerim dediğimde Londra’nın göbeğinde
hiç tanımadığım bir sokaktan,
hiç tanımadığım bir galeriden
hiç tanımadığım bir adam,
böyle adımı da
biraz yanlış telaffuzlerek
yani siz Türk sanatçı
Emre Yusufi olabilir misiniz? dedi bana.
Olay her şeyin değiştiği sıfır
noktası tam da o andı .
Çünkü fark ettim ki bazı
şeyler zaten olmuş .
Ben bazi işlerden becermişim, sadece
kaldırıp kaçım girip
Merhaba benim adım Emre Yusufi
demem kalmış
Tabi çok motive oldum bu motivasyonla.
Işte oradan çıktım,
aslında keşke şurada
sergilendi dediğim bir başka galeri vardı
Oraya girdim
ve kendimden çok daha emin ve özgüvenli
bir şekilde dedim ki ben galerinin
müdürüyle görüşmek istiyorum.
Bir hanfendi geldi buyrun dedi.
Dedim ben bir sanatçıyım,
sizin dediğiniz çok beğendiğimi
sizinle çalışmak istiyorum.
O da bir şaşırdı .
Hayhay tabii dedi.
Ama bir yandan da nasıl olacak?
işte oturduk, işlerimi gösterdim
ve işlerimi göğüslerken buraya
özellikle dikkatçekmek istiyorum
işlerimi çok iyi hazırlamış oldum
Instagram profili üzerinden gösterdim.
Bu Instagram profilinin hazır olması
konusu biraz şöyle bir şey.
İnsan şans ayağına geldiğinde
hazır olmalı.
Ben de şans ayağıma geldiğinde
hazırdım ve
İyi hazırlamış olduğum portfolyo mu
kendisine en iyi şekilde gösterebilirim.
Hazırdım kime pulunu çok önemi yok bence.
Konuştuk.
Vedalaştık, akabinde bundan sonra
ne olacak diye sordun.
İşte dedik eğer sizin için her şeyi
geçerse size bir mail gelecekte de
İstanbul’a döndüm, o mail geldi.
Galerinin adını ülkelerin adın taşıyan
soyal olan birinden gelmiş de olmayıp ve
diyordu ki galerimizin sahibi sizinle
tanışmak üzere ve belki çalışmak üzere
sizi Paris’e davet diyor.
Çok şık sevinmiştim, başına mutlu olmuştum
ve koşarak fuarı sektör içmekle
etmedim ve Paris'te gördüğüm galeri
Londra'da gördüğümden bile daha güzel
içeri girdim.
Nemli bir hoşgeldiniz diyen
insanlar beni karşıladı .
Hiç tanımadığım insanlar ve insan o an
sanata verilen değeri hemen anlıyor.
Üst kata çıktım çünkü benimle buluşan
bütün eserlerin basılmış halde
galerinin sahibi beni bekliyordu.
Uzun lafın kısası artık dünyanın iyi
galerilerinden birinde çalışıyorum.
Onlarla da onlar tarafından
temsil ediliyor.
Bugün belki o adımı atma cesaretine sahip
olmasam karşınızda olamaya bilirdim.
Tabi ben bu hikayede bunu çok çalışmaya,
yılmamaya ve azimle olmayan
borçluyum diyemeyeceğim.
Ama şunu söyleyebilirim.
Özgün fikirlere sahip olmama, kendime
karşı dürüst olmama
ve cesur olmama borçluyum diyebilirim.
Zaman eskisinden çok daha değerli ve
Hep değerler ya işte insan yeter ki
iştesin, çalışsın her şey olur.
Benim buna bir itirazım yok.
Aman şöyle diyorum.
İnsan önce kendine karşı dürüst olsun,
evet çalışsın, sonra her şeyi değil ama
doğru şey olsun ve böylece kendi
şansını kendi yarattı .
Ben dilimizin çok teşekkür ederim.